[Music]
all right this morning on the dish new
orleans has long been known for
fantastic food
and perhaps no name is more associated
with that tradition
than brennan's the third generation of
the brennan family is now in the
restaurant business with a variety of
venues
but there's a special affection for the
place where it all began
the original brennans which after some
difficult times is now
safely back in the family fold jamie wax
has the story
[Music]
it's hard to say what's more iconic in
the restaurant world
the familiar pink building on royal
street in the french quarter of new
orleans
or the name brennan's mounted on it in
brass script
my family took over in 1955 for their
one year of renovation
either way the very first of the now
dozens of restaurants owned by members
of the storied brennan family has been a
fine dining landmark for nearly seven
decades and it's famously pink it's
famous you know exactly where you are
when you're in front of brown
you absolutely know exactly where you
are it's always been pink the family
member currently in charge of brennan's
ralph brennan whose memories of the
restaurant go
back to his childhood when i was a child
i mean very young child
i used to come with my father and mother
here to eat
but in high school you got hired by your
aunt the legendary
ella brennan yes one of the the grand
doms of all restaurant tours all over
the world yes
exactly she had a plan for me and i
started in the kitchen as a prep cook
peeling shrimp and boning chicken and i
did that for about a month
and after that she said you're ready to
be promoted and they put me on the line
but as with many family businesses
disputes over how to run the restaurant
led to a deep and
bitter rift it was a very difficult time
culminated in 74.
the family had a disagreement they
decided to split the company up they
couldn't reconcile
and it turned out to be 40 years you
know over that time there was very
little communication between the
families
and it was very difficult because we
were all close we'd all been raised
together
we'll go through the doors here and into
the carriageway then in 2013 the
family's namesake restaurant came
back into ralph brennan's life then when
i saw that it was going to go into
bankruptcy
i figured i don't want to see it go
outside the family and that's why i got
involved in it it would have been
devastating
for someone else to take it because so
much of my family has invested in this
restaurant
this is the namesake and i didn't want
to see it leave and so
i took on you know the challenge with a
partner and it took us about 16 months
a year later when every last detail was
finally up to his standards
brennan extended an invitation to the
family including a special guest
who hadn't set foot in the place in 40
years
to your memories are better the car
pulls up
and in walks ella brennan again for the
first time in 40 years
tell me about that night it was very
emotional uh
for her she came in she was on a walker
and she took her time she went all
around
and then she told me she was very happy
and then as i said she sat with the
children it was special she never came
back
but it was a special night just to have
all the family together with the kids
[Music]
like his aunt ella brennan has a
reputation for spotting
and keeping talent good morning
from long-time employees like executive
kitchen manager titus perkins
you have to love what you do and i love
what i do
i work for a great company so for me
it's a no-brainer
to new hires like executive chef ryan
hacker
could you poach eggs in your sleep yes
yes
absolutely though they've stepped up
their dinner menu
brennen's continues to be known for
sumptuous
boozy celebratory daytime feasting
just don't call it brunch this is
a really opulent spread and it's just
breakfast it's just breakfast
this is our brioche french toast with a
strawberry sauce
over there you have one of our most
famous dishes and actually our number
one selling dish our egg sausard
this is a pastrami hash one of our new
dishes which is made with homemade
pastrami a poached egg and a chive
hollandaise sauce
egg st charles one of the older dishes
here that we've updated a little bit
the dish here is xrdu one of our oldest
dishes
it's on a cream spinach fried artichoke
heart
poached egg and a sauce sharon which has
a little bit of tomato flavor
in it throughout all the years of this
place and all the changes that have
happened
you do not call this brunch it's
breakfast exactly and it has been
breakfast
for over the 75-year period and what
would the ultimate breakfast be
without flawlessly cooked eggs
the beauty of a brennen's poached egg
is that it is perfect and consistent my
egg looks just like yours
it's exactly how you want it to be are
there secrets i can't poach eggs like
this at home
the secret to this business is just
incredible attention to detail it's
executing it every day
for every guest no meal this decadent
would be complete without dessert
including the most famous dish of all
here bananas foster
a brennan's original and a personal
favorite
and i have been banned from cooking it
at home because i've almost
set three kitchens in three cities on
fire corporate executive chef hailey
bitterman gave me a crash
course in preparing it you want it on
pretty high
okay their most popular dessert dates
back to a challenge in the 1950s from
ralph's uncle
owen brennan you've got this nice hot
pan okay
and you're going to add the dark rum
right
am i okay this is what see that
wow forward to flank for ralph brennan
preserving traditions like bananas
foster is about more than business
it's about family what do you think
ralph do you see yourself
in 40 years coming in on your own walker
and and seeing all your children running
this place
well i hope i'm here in 40 years but yes
i hope to
cheers it's breakfast let the tradition
continue
i love it let the tradition continue
and i will also say that across the
board people who work for ralph brennan
told me
about how much he has done for his
employees and their families
during the pandemic guys don't you love
the straight face he has
knowing how upset we are that there's an
empty table here
i would say that is great we love
hearing and it's great seeing
that this has stayed in the family and
all that you did but jamie you're back
with us
uh you're right you've been in new
orleans celebratory boozy daytime eating
and there's nothing here nothing this is
our favorite thing to do together it's
been a long time i'm sorry
just just stay over there jessica and
mercy all three of you
you all dropped the ball on this one
dropped the ball that moment with
uh aunt ella was so that was it's a
really tight-knit family
and they've had some risks but there's
been a lot of healing and they are just
they are the most hospitable they are
hosts for the restaurant and you didn't
burn yourself making the bananas foster
still have my eyebrows good stuff jamie
good stuff jamie